I get a feeling there's gonna be a riot
I don't read the newspapers because all
is time for safe space my new name for
this podcast the all grant podcast thank
you guys tune in I'll get into I want
change name I just want your name I just
like safe space I saw it the other day
somebody's writing bye-bye oh god the
safe space so I'm like you know what I
like that name this is safe place to
talk mad [ __ ] that's what the point of
this podcast is does anyone care they
won't care so thanks to an inn man i'm
very excited to be back in co my good
friend aaron aaron how's your weekend uh
you know went to a funeral that was no
that's rough how old you Aaron may I ask
3434 they start people suck your heroes
start the pathway to say 2016 the Reaper
man seriously I mean just can we get
this over with but I do have to I do
have a problem with people saying 2016's
the worst year ever because I got
married and that was pretty cool that is
cool i mean if you it off set I mean
it's like yeah we've lost all these
great musicians but Aaron got married
that's really the art I played prince at
the at the funeral that'd be [ __ ]
grave you just brought your keyboard you
had one of those guitar keyboards are
you just hug her purple rain and you
just started gyrating in front of
everybody and for a second they forgot
their loss no no we played several print
songs at the at our wedding reception
the drink was based on Prince it was
awesome so you're a big prince fan yeah
yeah yeah I mean I think everybody is to
play if you're a fan of just cool things
yeah that feel do you think he was a
power top or a hungry bottom little both
yeah I think you just like to have fun
yeah hey guys are really excited this
week I am in at the comic strip in
Edmonton I got a lot of nice new stuff
i'ma talk about I would love to have you
there please show up please come go to
our the comic strip dot CA I don't know
what you [ __ ] Canadians do your eat
with your web domain names but you know
so just do the comic strip Edmonton look
at me and of course you're using my
picture from ten years ago when it
looked like a young hopeful magician
ah torino that picture will haunt me
stop using it please Lord and then I
will be at the comedy I want to say cafe
oh the comedy bar in Chicago first
weekend in December shot boy come hang
out come get some and in the following
week we will be back in Las Vegas at the
naughty shell we had a great week I'll
get into that too oh why they change
name the podcast why not I don't know I
like twisted but i really like safe
space I think it's a cool name I just
think it's cool name I want safe space
with Sam triple-a because I just hate
the thought of shakes plate safe spaces
I hate the thought of adults being angry
at words I can't stand this like
grown-ups like on facebook emotionally
throwing up on their keyboards your feet
debate these people and they're just
like well aren't you an angry guy no man
uh if facts are angry yes I'm angry I'm
dropping facts you're running around
like a chicken with your head cut off
swung guys like oh I hope you enjoy the
president say I'm not go waste my time I
go don't waste your energy you're gonna
need it cuz you're running around like
the sky is falling you run around like a
chicken with head cut off doesn't matter
dude it doesn't matter we're getting all
that so it's just a name i like the name
safe space I'll work with it will grow
it will have fun ah why do I have my
glasses on sorry about that i had a
great weekend in Vegas man cool dude I
am on the biggest jumbotron in Vegas
yeah it's huge dude it's [ __ ] huge I
mean dude it's on the front jumbotron of
Planet Hollywood we were walking with
day days like oh my god she looks up big
naughty show on the jumbotron they got
three Jumbotrons it just rotates on all
three nice it is so cool to see that
I've always visioned that I visualized
that I visualize that and it happened
and it was so cool to see and that runs
every day over and over again which
picture
you're using this how you saying they're
using the if you go they cut down the
naughty show experience video off of
youtube I said to them and they edited
it down they took out Whitney Cummings I
go a few sure if what he tries buying
she sees her picture on there I'm gonna
get my [ __ ] ripped so I had her
edited out and now try and do this [ __ ]
I mean it's so big and it's just cool
man cuz I know I see guys playing the
laugh factory down there they show
picture and I'm on a Jumbotron and it's
very cool I very much I get that feeling
it's I remember the four it's so
interesting dude Vegas is the first
place i started doing stand-up Vegas is
like there's this kind of new thing I'm
kind of getting into it's called punk
rock comedy it's like in-your-face pull
no punches fight fascism like I like in
my opinion I'll get in the political
correctness I think that's the new
McCarthyism oh yeah okay and we'll get
into that and that's what punk rock
comedy is end up and the home of where
punk rock comedy I think started is
Vegas and the godfather of it is Doug
Stanhope Doug Stanhope start out there
his attitude do you know Doug Stanhope
was so good at telemarketing that they
gave him his own office Wow and he stay
I'm so funny because sample do anything
for a joke that was that what I used to
be known as like if he thought I could
get a joke out of it he would do it and
he once did gay phone sex on acid he
dropped acid and he knew some guys who
did gay phone sex so he went and he did
it and he would had this great joke
about how he's telling this guy he want
his big black dick to just open him up
and makes [ __ ] look like a empty
mayonnaise jar with a [ __ ] with with
a knife history here on the core he's so
good right um so it's punk rock comedy
and that's kind of a naughty show and we
had our best weekend yeah great it's
very interesting because I mean like I
within playing a Hollywood I am like the
20th show there there within the malls
and everything there's about 20 shelves
I'd say uh maybe that's exaggeration 10
well I mean there's a lot of shows also
a lot of sweet jackets to look at a lot
of sweet jackets a lot of fun like data
will go off gambling and this gorgeous
cougar from Ohio just started talking to
me and I'm not looking to get what you
know cheat on Dana but I mean it's just
fun to hit on people and just use your
kung-fu but you never would want to do
anything but she's having then data
walked up and I wasn't even doing
anything i was just talking and you all
make me feel like she just caught you
balls deep you're like oh you know I
want to be Kobe and put a
three-million-dollar ring on her finger
because I thought maybe um so it was
really cool dude we had more we sold
more tickets for a weekend than we have
ever and Jocelyn sharp the very funny
comic out of Vegas is the head of the
social media and street team and she's
Street teaming it and it was great dude
fleshlight shout-out to our good friends
of flesh like Christina k a fleshlight
got us a bunch of fleshlights and we
gave away and a listener who listened to
actually punch drunk I want it and it
was great dude I mean I was taught I was
on fire this weekend it was so much fun
I just love creating a room where you
can talk mad [ __ ] so the rooms were
packed and that was really great that's
very but friday night was a little
slower than that saturday night was a
little slower than friday night because
there was a giant Trump protest then
walk right down the middle Vegas
Boulevard right about 30 minutes before
shows folks start that just stopped all
traffic that's not even where his hotel
is it's like butts like here's my
problem with these protests you're
protesting in cities that voted for
Hillary like what are you doing get that
that's like going to berg and yelling i
love rompers you know like yeah we get
it we get it we like whoppers too that's
why we work here we like whoppers that's
that we get it you're it's a cojer
you're just yelling you're preaching to
the choir you want to show me you care
you want to show me how much balls you
got you go to [ __ ] Waco Texas and
[ __ ] march on stop some traffic in
Waco Texas with some Trump [ __ ] pro
how about Dayton Florida I mean Dayton
Ohio you ever been to Dayton Ohio that's
what i call ghetto country that's where
like hood [ __ ] farmers live
like they listen to hip-hop but they
walk around in flannels and have mullets
I used to break dance with a mullet that
was ghetto country way back today dude
those people shoot you I mean if you're
going to protest protests in places that
didn't vote for don't be i mean you but
what kind of protest will it take Oh
what kind of part and if you're gonna
protest man I was like if you're gonna
protest inve in la do it by the best buy
let's burn that [ __ ] down give me an
xbox [ __ ] yo for triple Xbox and either
players I need the virtual reality but
chic Abu Trump I feel like you're gonna
do do do do do it there take that [ __ ]
there I just got to know how quiet is it
at that Clinton Clinton Foundation right
now you think any of the phones are at
all ringing at all nothing I bet you
everybody they're secretly just like
update my resume huh destabilize Latin
America to help bring her come ba ba ba
ba Chelsea Clinton just walk around good
look busy guys look but I know the
phones are ringing right now but there
goes so look busy you know if you're
standing up you can clean up look busy
now I'm gonna come back and you don't
worry the feelings look busy everybody
it is quiet at the Clinton Foundation
yeah I think I mean dude this and this
is my last round the election Aaron this
is it this election dumb be evil drop
the mic walk out that's it don't be evil
man that's really what it is idiots
idiots idiots idiots everywhere and dude
Obama just said and we all know he's
black Jesus just said Trump is the new
president is the next president let's
stop doing his dumb [ __ ] it's over
cerros what's his name Greg Sarah what's
his name Saros the billionaire Greek guy
everybody thinks he's funding these
protests go away
one's piss at the Russians but we're
fine with some Greek [ __ ] if you got
paid to protest more people to be doing
it what do you think they're doing a
casting was it this time I'll a casting
hey if you are you're looking for extra
work do I walk down the street to [ __ ]
traffic up fifty dollars in the sandwich
do that [ __ ] on slauson I say it all the
time I don't understand when you protest
and you stop traffic how you think
people are gonna be cool with your cause
yeah if you want a protest go fix their
house Mulder lawn boy likes matter what
are you doing buy clothes man mowing the
lawn you know what thank you thank me
you could be protesting for the
legalization of marijuana and handing
out joints but if you're stopping
traffic no yeah nobody's gonna get
behind you ya know if your [ __ ] aids
walked all the time in LA everyone's
walking for AIDS you know you think I'm
I feel bad it just took me two hours to
get a latte go [ __ ] yourself I'm give a
[ __ ] stop it ok uh anyways back to the
fun things election Dave Chappelle did
Sarah Night Live you see that hear about
it I haven't seen it yet no I know that
Hillary hallelujah thing though yeah
what do you think of that Kate McKennon
[ __ ] great she's awesome she's
awesome do you think she's just crying
cuz she's that could be able to do that
she's like next four years baby gonna be
doing this impression nothing yeah
nothing yeah I think she's great is she
lesbian by the way no I don't think so
I'd love to hit it yeah cuz she got
those big teeth there's something about
a woman where her teeth are too big for
her mouth I thought she was hot in
Ghostbusters which is weird oh you saw
ghostbusters yeah how was it it wasn't
pet it's it's funny you know so it
misses some some key points but it's
fine yeah there's a lot of people rely
movie magic a lot now a lot you're like
God's movie magic keep the plot moving
goat you know I wanna go see dr. strange
have you seen that no I hear it's
phenomenal yeah i'm gonna go i'm going
to see tonight i'm going to see i'll get
in that later
Dave Chappelle doesn't show Dave
Chappelle did a bit I've been doing
almost verbatim oh wow and it's like
obviously it's parallel thinking I've
had that with a couple people I've had
it with Doug Stanhope I've had it with
Joe Rogan we parallel thinking yeah yeah
but the problem is they're all bigger
names than me and I lose the bit yeah I
can canary I had a bit about the the
Orlando shooter going to a gay club and
he yelled ah Isis everyone's like he's a
nice as he yelled Isis I'm like dude I
yell wu-tang all the time doesn't mean
I'm in the wu-tang clan and I did the
whole bit about being on grindr going
undercover [ __ ] dudes in the ass
sucking tix like how deep undercover are
you did all that and he said the M word
and he said giving handjobs on Sarah
nightlife think how crazy is that what's
after hours you can you don't think
that's weird I'm not in for I'm not done
that guy's been dirty since the 90s I'm
for it it's after eleven thirty p.m. it
should be fun I think it should be fine
you should think you so Aaron you're on
the record saying there should be
fisting on TV after after midnight I'm
cool that me if I want to see guys
[ __ ] watching some unsuspecting
Russian girls ass I'm cool that's where
we're going bro if you're cool with that
no I'm care I can do words or words I
hate beeping of words yeah don't beat
the work we don't know no it is yeah it
doesn't make I'll think I didn't hear I
know what you said but thank God my
little tender ears didn't hear you say
[ __ ] and I just heard instead we know
what you're saying nobody cares so I
lost a bit I lost the bed I'm gonna miss
it it's a good bit it's good bet it
makes me sad it was a [ __ ] great bit
when I came up with it and then I
remember him leaving The Comedy Store
and Marilyn rice cups like top stop I'm
like what don't you pouches did your bed
I'm like Thank You Marilyn I appreciate
that what do you want me to run on stage
and say something not that she was doing
that she was just trying to tell me
about and what could I do there's
nothing I could do especially when you
jacked Chappelle you
don't wanna [ __ ] with a c8 Chappelle
jeez I thought he look I thought he
looked a little a little different yeah
dude it's like when you all he does
stand-up that's an hour a night he's not
doing it every night he's doing it once
or twice a week maybe only an hour it's
three hours Yeah right so he's bored you
got a lot of downtime so he's just like
carrot top just skim board and just a
[ __ ] look like a carrot top he's been a
CH him for a good 15 years I mean you
soon ACH back when like it's like it was
like horse tranquilizers like really bad
a [ __ ] not the smooth [ __ ] now the good
stuff he's doing way back now he's
that's why he's got like Ninja Turtles
coming out of his shoulders you ever see
him he's got [ __ ] latina eyebrows it
looks like golden arches of Latina aye
bruh it's like really bad he did he's
just bored I mean if your carrot top can
you just go out and have fun like dude
let's go pup pup like there's nothing
you could do there you get mobbed by
everybody and everybody's touching me
all your muscles gun is this real is it
we're when people i do like butt
implants I wouldn't know if I've ever
seen him really I can tell and they're
just not hot at all what works for kids
does not work for asses it barely works
for tits at sometimes when your legs and
ass look like the letter P it doesn't
work you know where it goes straight and
just jumps right out yeah like it
doesn't work like a great ass is a
gradual built yeah it doesn't just jump
right out like you're like pee it
doesn't work it's just unattractive and
like these girls in Vegas I don't do lap
dancing I can't stand strippers i like i
like i mean my Instagram is just ass
it's just a feat of ass it's just a feat
of ass and I love when I'm watching like
major events happen like even on the
election just tits and ass they don't
care but it's just like when you get lap
dance from these strippers they just
talk [ __ ] to you like that the whole
time there's no likes reductions like
what do you do
ah it's so weird shut up that's [ __ ]
up shut up so stupid God as you just
punch you it's like am I paying you for
this I did this show I did the show in
Vegas and and I my friend Gooch is very
great Vegas comedian could could be a
good comic in la if you wanted to move
here but he's got a good job he's doing
radio authors like a three well I'm like
don't you got a good gig just build I'm
telling everybody man if you're a comic
you listeners I'm sure nobody does but
if you listen to this man build your
YouTube page that's the best advice I
can give you built up you spent as much
time building your YouTube page as you
do building your Twitter followers and
your Instagram followers if you put all
your energy in the YouTube you'll blow
up if you could get a hundred thousand
followers on YouTube you're cooking with
gas you will get booked into anywhere
you want that's kind of what i'm trying
to do man this will this video will go
on there I'm just trying to build it but
it's like sorry I'm doing the show and
at the naughty show in in Vegas it's
going Gucci has me on his radio show we
promote shell would give away a couple
tickets some people get these two people
in the front row show up for them they
all look like they're like from The
Nightmare Before Christmas like their
characters from there just like the best
way described them is goth hillbilly
goth hillbilly like like Suicide Squad
meets line dancing I don't know if that
makes any sense but it's like it's like
who the guys in our goth right who the
kids in arm and cut in high school
though he's smoked and they all dress in
black yessir girls gosh yeah yeah but
the cool kids got so they're trying to
be cool but they have a hillbilly look
anyways are in the front row the two
people the backer laughs there so
they're doing front just nothing nothing
not laughing it I actually watch them
trying to fight laughing they're trying
to fight it I go why are you fighting
this why are you fighting laughing
that's like going to a strip are
ordering a lap dance and playing TV fans
00 d fats boom boom you know just you
like you're running you're doing Krav
Maga on these sexy [ __ ] se1 do Krav
Maga god this time flies over having fun
i'm going to talk about two more thing
sideways so Aaron let me talk to you
sure I have an album come I was gonna
put on double alongside not to I I like
the idea a double album I do it's just
not the way you're doing it not just a
double album but like i just don't think
i get it i just like this guy who's at
it he's editing my [ __ ] he's telling me
I have an extra [ __ ] track and I just
can't find it I just don't want to put
it out i don't know how it it's an extra
truck so maybe I'll just hold off
because I want to get it out before
Christmas and it's just not gonna happen
so if I if I put out double elbow it's
going to be have to be after January so
basically I don't want to get too much
into the actual specifics of who it is
but I'm looking at a couple record
labels and the deals just suck they suck
but i'm so tired of doing DIY shed I'm
always doing boba fett man on my own I'm
I'm a lone assassin i wanna i want to
stop being Rudolph I want playing the
reindeer games let me be in so do i take
the shitty deal and have them put out my
album or gonna put it all on my own and
I do by myself it's like they own the
rights to it it's like I get paid way
down the line it's just like yeah that's
rough it's rough do i plague like I'm
just tired of being on the outside you
know and that this day in age you're
really not going to make a lot of money
off your CDs anyways you just kind of
put them out as a [ __ ] calling card
so people can see how hard you rock and
then the club goes how many CDs he's got
out this will be the third if I put out
mm now before you know
I don't [ __ ] know man it's weird it's
like this town is all about you you get
[ __ ] until you can [ __ ] until you can
[ __ ] people you give [ __ ] right it's
weird and nothing these guys are bad
people let's just say I have a business
model it's working for them that's what
they work and that's the deal do you
want access what they do and then you
gotta kind of play a little game they're
nice people there's no I have no
problems with them but the deals weird
do i do the deal or do I not do the deal
I don't know man I'm just tired of doing
everything everything I do is on my own
I'm a lone assassin dog I don't mind it
I just that's how I've always been I
rise thing about that the other day when
i was when i was thinking of just my
comedy career like how i have my name on
this jumbotron at the hard rock and i
remember only like a mile away two miles
away my name was on my first marquee
there and it was a show that i developed
which has always been my thing always
developing my i'm producing my own
shelves I've always been DIY I was DIY
before it was DIY because I just I'm
just have a first of all I've crippling
social anxiety like I can I just freaked
out I cannot hang out in an environment
like I can do a stand-up like I talked
to Russell Peters he says he's gonna put
me in his neck Serena shell I go just
give me five min to that I just want to
feel it I want to know it's like to play
a [ __ ] arena oh right I'm sure it's
it's gotta be chaos yeah but I just want
to feel it I just want to feel it um but
it's like I didn't play an arena but
then I if you put me in front of a you
know in a cocktail party of like 40
people I'm freaking the [ __ ] out to the
point where people think I'm like I'm
standoffish because I just can't hang
out the idea I just have crippling
social anxiety so it's like that's a big
reason why I produce my own [ __ ] that I
want to talk to people I can just do my
own thing so that
the thing what do I do do I play ball or
do I not play ball because i think i can
get it up to number one if i do it on
the right day I'd love to have the
number one you know and then they'd be
like all you did really well it's do an
hour special with you then go back and
do cuz didn't Jay Larson just put out an
album yeah with all things comedy know
who they do with himself no it might be
another distributor and now he's gonna
film an hour there's no way I mean maybe
does have two hours is done he's
probably doing the best he's doing the
best of ya of his old shits what you
should do Bert Kreischer our was fought
phenomenon so no that's the best bird
cry sure it's how you should do it
that's how you should do it so that's
why I'm into I would love to know what
everybody thinks let's get into I know
it's very weird I don't necessarily want
to talk sports on this podcast but I
would like to talk a little we'll go
through real quick UFC 205 did you see
it no really yeah you have no desire
beat on punch chunk all the time that's
all I know about it is punch-drunk you
know lock down cuz that's we we educate
yeah yeah we educate the [ __ ] masses
done but beyond that I've known well
just let you here's a funny thing and
I'll I'm talk about on podcast around
but up 205 was a big success a huge
success it would like they really do the
big cards match the hype because it's
usually stacked and people are so
nervous to get knocked out they they
fight more not to to lose than the wind
yeah and they're very tentative and it
gets boring damn not this not this card
no people knocking each other the [ __ ]
out it was everything my god miesha tate
retired i'm washing her fight every time
he should take a punch in the face my
dick cried a little bit just cried yeah
she's too hot you like that you know she
you know and that's just the weight
women are like they want it I bet she
wants to have kids she's 30 now she
wants have some kids that's how it is
that's how you see an actress
says they get bigger than a hip that got
30 32 33 agent they want to have kids
and then they disappear for a while and
then he come back it's just how it is
yeah but infighting you you can't really
come back no you can't especially now I
mean like looking female look at tennis
like especially female do you know how
rare it is to be a William sister and
last that long but now they're coming
out that they're on like prescription
like like performance-enhancing for like
they're weird anxiety and they've been
playing forever like wikileaks release
those I don't know why you gotta release
those just just stick to the [ __ ]
political stuff you know oh I want to
get into that oh this whole thing about
edwin soon but i'm gonna move on i'm
done with the election I'm done okay so
UFC 202 of 205 was great ah the Russian
is amazing nah when I'm an egg off
whatever his name of Dominum an egg off
I'm [ __ ] his name off but he's insane
and he wants a piece of McGregor and I'm
gonna tell him he's gonna have to fight
but they're not gonna give him McGregor
until they've absolutely ran out of
everybody else cuz he will destroy
mccarter later on him dry yeah he's he's
just in the wrong class I mean the guy
is huge for that age and for that way
class he's fighting Michael Johnson I
was like goddamn e so big and he's just
a bear and he's angry because they won't
give them fight but you were down for
two years you didn't fight for two years
because you got injured they're not
going to give you a title fight if
you're super injury prone it's just not
so McGregor is going to fight Nate Diaz
again that's what he's asking for which
is the trilogy which is what I talked
about it's not about records it's about
wars I'm telling you this I think Nate
Diaz could win that I honestly believe
Nate Diaz was smart enough to know to
hold McGregor up and I'm not saying that
he threw the fight but it was in
everybody's best interest that that
Conor McGregor won the second fight
between him and Diaz it's mess that's
more my everybody including d
in all his family and the city of sock
stockton it was in their best interest
that McGregor won that fight and they're
gonna have a third fight and it's gonna
be [ __ ] huge it's gonna be [ __ ]
huge how did the second one end was it
uh knocking out or no it was they went
to the judges yeah dude here's the thing
about McGregor you're going to have to
knock them out or choke him out you will
never win unless you absolutely dominate
them it's going to be almost impossible
to win a judge's decision against
MacGregor he's just too important to the
UFC now he's asking for a piece of the
pie how do you feel about that I mean
that seems weird that does seem weird
I'll know if I go that far cuz he's like
I mean dude if he took a break they'd be
[ __ ] who's our big stars now Jon Jones
is gone Ronda Rousey's in cuoco town
Ronda Rousey is in cucuta and run Ronda
Rousey star dims even more with the fact
when you see how conor mcgregor operates
which is he'll fight almost everybody
like he'll he's jumping up and down from
way classes like that's amazing Ronda
Rousey is ran from cyborg I still think
they got give her a 145 division give
her the 145 division why not why not man
just tell her stop calling out run but
Rhonda's only got one or two fights on
her pen ah here's the thing about Pena
she is a she's a warrior man now her
style fits in to what ronda rousey feast
on which his fighters coming forward and
she just does a judo chop throws and she
grounds and pounds on him arm bars that
it plays into ronda rousey's think but I
think Pena is another level the
evolution of female MMA with the
exception of cyborg who is so I called
it on this podcast for I'll get the Jim
Brown a female MMA where you could drop
her 20 30 years into the future and she
would still [ __ ] up fighters from there
she's so
ahead of her time and we're not used to
a woman like that having a bill like
that yes she did steroids but she gets
tested like everybody else she's insane
she's an incredible fighter ah gotta be
honest with you I feel really bad for
Chris Weidman I mean dude loses the
fight he campaigned for MMA in New York
got it got put on the card hey I thought
I had the fight going and wyman always
does these Gamble's he shot like you
know against rock hard you just swinging
he did a roundhouse kick got caught got
ground-and-pound knocked out he did a
shoe here now that's not as much of a
gamble obviously because that he's a
great wrestler but so is it Yoel Romero
Yoel Romero you know that guy dude
Romero's built like it someone from the
300 the guy is shredded the guys in gay
porn shape that's how shredded he is
he's in gay like I can see him walking
down Santa Monica Boulevard on a Friday
night trying to get some boy ass that
got weird but the point is he's
incredible shape and they his side told
him his corner told you get you gotta
knock him out and he shot and dude he
just need why me rain head and knocked
him out someone said when Wyman got
knocked out they were at the UFC fight
and they literally heard oh no the
fighting and he's gonna be pissed
sometimes I don't realize how many how
much people love punch drop yeah it's
the premier sports comedy podcast ah so
that's it and then kind of macgregor
offer you then you had joanna champion
literally I mean she won but she got the
[ __ ] kicked out of her by the other
polish fighter her face literally look
like a Romulan after she looked like
straight out Star Trek she had the big
nose and the weird things that you know
what was he called what was the loo well
worth it what was it it was the what was
he called on Star Trek next generation
the Romulan
woof or wharf is a Klingon yeah Klingon
he looks like a Klingon he looked I
could cling on she looked like a toke
Worf to Klingon had all the weird like
had the weird skulls like she got the
[ __ ] kicked out of her it's so hard to
watch a chick now tony hinchcliffe is it
once isn't is attracted to join a gym I
think she's cute I mean I mean it's hard
to be ugly when you're young when you're
in your young toy it's worth even fat
chicks are [ __ ] in their early 20s
like I like a 20 year old fat chick
still has you know a gleam in her eye
you know you want Steelers soul that's
kind of like so it's like scuba I it
would be weird to watch tony hinchcliffe
[ __ ] joanna champion it would just be
like are you guys brothers and sisters
and then once I got past that I'd
probably have a full boner and just
[ __ ] go I just y'all to hang slip go
your haunted puppet go [ __ ] that Klingon
[ __ ] that click on your heart good
puppet yeah Tony Hitler [ __ ] enjoy her
champions like Mortal Kombat [ __ ] we
have haunted puppet versus Klingon and
then conor mcgregor the heights real is
he one of the grace ever not yet but
he's there he's in the discussion your
to chew your a to division champ you
beat you beat jose aldo who had lost in
a decade and you go in there and beat
Eddie Alvarez in New York any other eyes
is a warrior but I knew was going to
happen man you see them stand together
for eddie alvarez was so small compared
to conor mcgregor and we saw what
happened Eddie had to leap into try to
hit him because his reach wasn't big
enough you know it's so intricate Connor
goes up and way class he seems to get
bigger whereas frankie edgar is the
exact opposite where every time he drops
away class he seems to get smaller
Frankie Edgar's never the bigger fighter
in no matter what fight classy fights it
it's almost like he's one of those
Russians schult salt shakers were you
opening there's a little more Russian
little smaller Russian that's at Frankie
Edgar it's like I'm going to 145 open
them here's a smaller agar i'm going to
135 open him there's a smaller agar he
can fight it 150
any be the tiniest even being on the
planet it's gotta be hard to fight in
your home city the pressure like the
wyman get knocked knocked out like that
is when I went back to UNLV and did
stand up and they hated me I basically
got almost booed off stage and I
literally walked about two hundred
freshman like radar high school freshman
is like what do I have to talk to these
[ __ ] about they've all been in there
safe space safe space what they look
good they do they're very dry all right
real quick we're gonna end the show on
imma take your questions here we go all
right let's get into these questions dog
it's question time it's time for
questions you got your questions I'll
answer them it's question time it's time
for questions it's time for questions
you got some questions I'll take I'll
answer them okay from putty lard face
Perry can I sleep on your couch no no
even though you bust my balls all my
time on Bob politics I think you think
i'm like super conservative I'm really
liberal dude I just won't get behind a
Sith Lord bro but no you cannot crash on
my couch my girlfriend would not like
that last night I to sleep I mike water
would Pollyanna sleep Pollyanna sleeps I
we have to work around Pollyanna I
literally got in the bed last time like
I'm gonna sleep on a couch poly animal
like Pollyanna has been with us for five
or six years she's still for a smart dog
she still doesn't understand parallel
and perpendicular she just loves to go
perpendicular between us cuz she wants
to touch Dana she wants to touch me but
then it just [ __ ] my back up cuz I'm
like doing some weird like some weird
yoga positions so I don't disturb her
and then when I wake her up she crawls
at me and then Dana yells at me don't
wake her up she's trying to sleep I'm
like I pay the [ __ ] bills hair what am
I my dad I'm the [ __ ] suddenly my dad
I'm yeah my dog sleep when you pay for
your bells you can see why you want to
what's ridiculous
no buddy you can all right is it a safe
space anywhere away from aa pollocks and
sneaky Cambodians I never dropped Jesus
that's just rude Steve the Messiah do
you regret ever helping Steve Randolph
no i don't and that's all I'm I get into
okay um oh that's a heavy one yeah that
was Steve Messiah and maybe give the
story at the end of the International
bad boys I really like both but maybe a
bit too much crazy in the mix yeah I
like Steve Steve and I will hopefully at
some point make friends up again you
know I think Steve's a good guy think he
means well you know my only thing will
I'll say is this and I don't want to
throw gas in a fire but just because
your feelings are hurt doesn't mean you
can scorch the earth my feelings get
hurt all the [ __ ] time it doesn't
mean I go and I try to hurt everybody
and that's it Steve got mad because I
said he's wearing fake glasses and he's
affected by Hollywood and I stand by it
if you're walking on fake-ass glasses on
that some dumb [ __ ] I love him to death
I wish a number love we saw each other
on election night we shook hands we
smiled you know I wish Steve well he's
doing this character in us motivational
speaker on stage I hope it hits and he
blows up because I know Steve wants to
be famous and I hope he does but at the
end of the day Steve does hasn't done
drugs or drank in 15 years but you know
what just cuz your feelings hurt doesn't
mean you can go and scorch the earth man
my feelings you don't make times I get
told i'm fat or I'm old all the time man
do I start [ __ ] hurting everybody who
says it no you [ __ ] suck it up like
an old man and you move on you think of
grandpa anybody give a [ __ ] about your
Grandpa's feelings healthy big old man
idiot at work all the time won't you
grandpa to smile smirk or punch the guy
in the face oh by the way almost gotten
fight the other day oh so I'm out trying
to go up to Charlie's editing my CD I
tried to go up his to hill to get to him
and there's a space between the car in
the next Lane in the car behind him I'm
moving the car moving to go that space
the car behind me guns it trying to cut
me off on my
did stop so that one parked out here
tank tank tank and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is that I look and I knows the guy
behind me is throwing pennies at my car
I'm like ah now tripley's got a half the
[ __ ] choke a [ __ ] so I go what the
[ __ ] man quit [ __ ] i drive in and my car
i drive my car into gases he pulls and
I'm like oh we're about to do this I got
my car he gets out he's huge like he's
like a 68 black guy and I like I'm
fighting a tower he just keeps going up
oh I'm like bit a ton it's be done at
least I'm like ah [ __ ] this can't get
bad but he's throwing [ __ ] my car like
what the [ __ ] man he goes dude I'll
[ __ ] kick your ass I'm like wherever
you are do do not think of that at all
hoping to god somebody will jump in but
guess what nobody breaks up fights
anymore you know why they're too busy
filming them so he put on
worldstarhiphop so he comes up to me and
then I know says he's Sean taking over
so I got lucky that I got the only 68
black guy who's happened to be flaming
gay that's has road rage so he comes up
to me it's like [ __ ] you bit and he
pushed me I'm like ah i knows when
people push they don't want to fight no
they just want to and I go okay Sam I
can either you could either talk mad
[ __ ] get our mo crazy and get the
[ __ ] [ __ ] kicked out of you or you
can just explain this off and this other
guy that I knew from some AAA meetings
was talking this guy down and I'm like
be quiet then I walked to my car and I
realized I have a bat my car and I'm
like if it gets crazy I'm a police bad i
go to find a bath Dana move the bat all
the way to the back trunk right by where
the guy is don't ladies don't move your
[ __ ] boyfriend's weapons from their
car they're there for a reason we're
gonna kick ass so in case of 6 foot a
black guy who's flaming gay wants to
kick your ass you might need a bat
probably shove up his ass make him feel
better ok so that's that that was that
so my point is just cuz your feelings
are hurt doesn't mean you could scorch
the earth I love Steve and that's all I
gotta say ah ah Khan template political
side do you find it troubling that the
Russians successfully
remained in the US election and that is
from Michael Jayhawk Michael I don't
have it's ridiculous that people are
still calling this Russian ship first of
all there's no proof of it one and two
by acknowledging and saying it's the
Russians they're acknowledging that the
emails are real you should be more
concerned about what's in the emails
then we release them and I'll say one
more time for the last time to get mad
at the Russians will ever release that
the emails to get mad at them is like
getting mad at the LAPD cuz oj killed
two people you should be more mad at
wise in the emails then release the
emails that's my last take on that one
white women in the 30s turning political
correctness of the fascism one hundred
percent its new McCarthy as a man
McCarthyism was a bunch of people trying
to play ball with McCarthy running
around accusing everybody of being a
communist off a hunches not based on any
facts trying to ruin their lives and get
them fired from their jobs which is
exactly what people do on Twitter and
Facebook with political correctness
because you did a tweet that people
didn't like he all of a sudden they're
gonna call you a racist and it's there's
no bit at least McCarthy was an elected
official knots anybody with a [ __ ]
Twitter handle can cause it call anybody
anything and that's where we live in and
it's ridiculous Newt Gingrich is also
talking about bringing back the house on
American committee so there's a real
McCarthyism as well Newt Gingrich needs
to get out my up kick that [ __ ]
jack-o'-lantern it's [ __ ] ass thank
you [ __ ] him I mean dude don't know
here's an ocean dude listen Trump is not
good dude I can nobody's argue with that
but you can't argue with me about the
Trump campaign unless one you've read
the emails and you've done enough
research on emails that you can discuss
the emails cuz of discuss Trump without
discussing why people rejected Hillary
it's a wasted argument you can't do just
don't come at me with your feelings are
hurt Oh was enjoyable Papa I mean like
for every bad thing Trump did there's a
video of Hillary i doing
back same thing and dude and you know
maybe we needed this maybe we needed
this [ __ ] idiot to get elected so
that the Liberals stop with the
sensitivity and get the real issues stop
crying about your feelings getting hurt
nobody [ __ ] cares as long as you're
not hurting people stealing anything
from people and not harming children we
shouldn't give a [ __ ] what you're doing
you don't like other people I don't give
a [ __ ] but don't pass laws that's it
it's just like I'm a liberal I'm a
liberal I'm the liberal cross all the
board I Hillary Clinton sold us out and
she got caught and that's the end of it
Russians have nothing to do with this
you should be more mad that ah ba ba ba
how critical is cunnilingus in an
emotionally healthy relationship well I
think you got to eat girls [ __ ] once a
while if you like it if you like eating
[ __ ] some guys like eating [ __ ] I like
eating [ __ ] I like like an [ __ ]
that's who I am you know but girls don't
want all the time you know that I got
the whole you know we talked about last
week with Sarah Tiana thinking like guys
want porn sex we really don't oh really
wants to bang dump and go to sleep that
you never see that in the poor now why
is that ever happened dude blows load
goes to sleep for the rest of the porn
how great would that poor hey hey dude
quiet honey he's sleeping this my
favorite are the porn we need we need
that more than condoms in porn yeah one
hundred percent we need more realistic
porn yep hot give a hot take I know I
got the garner 81 I know he's a friend
of mine give a hot taking all the celebs
who said there they'll move to Canada if
Trump won hey dude I know it's a fake
article but some put an article that Kim
Kim Kim Kardashian Kanye West or leave
the country because Trump won maybe the
orangutan [ __ ] election isn't so bad
I mean that's a great first step if you
go I dude I'm elected guess who's gone
I'll greet this very bad celebrity you
[ __ ] geek out i'll let you kick out
one illegal can we do that is that okay
zaza Liam picked the illegals noce like
my friend sent me my friend
and set me I email the this really hot
chick is having her green card here her
name is here ah her name is clear Scott
and she's smoking hot and she might get
kicked out cuz her green card is is up
for renewal she doesn't the four grand
and I'm like we should all dude America
should be a VIP party where only you
want in you better be [ __ ] only
good-looking people getting into this
VIP party no ugly people only sexy
clears pretty hot you guys go to
generosity calm go to the don't let them
take Claire and donate five bucks keep a
hot chick in here now the truth is if
she really wanted to stay she would
sugar daddy it that's sugar dating now
it's sugar dating which is a nice way
saying I'm I'm escort but I'm not a
hooker we cuddle first you're paying for
the cuddle the pussy's for free that's
really what sugar daddy dating is that's
how women up sugar dating is completely
legal prostitution illegal cuz why
prostitutions when guys want it any
sugar dating is when women need
something so they need money so they put
it out so that's legal but prostitution
illegal where's your head where's your
hat nope nobody's with me on that one
okay so uh one more question that we're
al will you do a show in Simi Valley yes
hire me ah biggest letdown and positive
experience you with a person who looked
up to I don't know man I think I've
never really been let down by every
anybody I kind of like you got to know
what you getting into with people let me
be on sir I kind of said the marc
maron's never had me on his podcast he
offered to me a bunch times when it
first started now me every time I ask
him to do it he's like I can't get it
I'm like okay dude I'm not gonna [ __ ]
ask you anymore ah that's about it man
that's about it oh I want really quick
you say thank you to Pamela Anderson i
walking into this real one more
thing about the Russian emails and then
we're out of here I know it's 50 meant
the Russian emails everybody's calling
Russian emails in leak listen dude
whistleblowers like this don't do it for
the money okay I don't you think edward
stone did it for money he's in reason
banish to [ __ ] Russia I can do differ
bhama wants to go out the greatest
friend ever he should he should pardon
Snowden he did that everyone big hail
Lord Jesus he would do that you think
Julian Assange wants to live in a
[ __ ] closet where is he in Sweden no
he's in the Ecuadorian Embassy in London
yeah yeah you think he wants that he
wants to live there know how many rubles
would it take for you to live in a
[ __ ] closet for years on end there's
not enough rubles in the world and
they're rubles right Russians have
rubles Yeah right highly right the only
saving grace is that Pamela Anderson
keeps going over to his house Thank You
Pamela Anderson huh thank you for
bringing that sweet 2,000 to snatch you
got that was hot back in two thousand
two poor Julian sighs now he's gone foul
[ __ ] Tommy Lee it's probably
cannonballing into that [ __ ] but [ __ ]
you man thank you Pamela Anderson
forgetting it for helping out a freedom
fighter I hope they let him go the the
rape case is [ __ ] the Raiders are in
what else play ball Sam gotcha well guys
I hope you guys if you're in Canada you
can come see me at the edmonton comedy
at the comic strip in Edmonton I'm very
excited ah thank you for listening to
say space guys if you see this on
youtube just please subscribe I'm put
down something every day i love you guys
Aron things for let me do this and I
will see you all next tomorrow on punch
drunk bye guys doing solo no okay